[Musique]
dans la france entière
l'innovation est assez tristesse sur la
garonne
la réole inondé donnent le spectacle
type de toutes les villes riveraines
depuis bordeaux jusqu'à toulouse et l'on
craint que les codes catastrophique de
1917-1924 ne soit dépassée par une
nouvelle crue aujourd'hui menaçant
dans le bassin de la seine même
spectacle désolant à montereau le
confluent de la scène et de l'yonne
accentue l'importance du désastre
une épaisse tristesse couvre ses coins
hier encore heureux et vivant
les campagnes riveraine disparaissent
sous un mètre d'eau c'est une sorte de
trajet que désolation que traduit ces
images prison plus fort de la crue
[Musique]
le président dans les france et le
ministre de l'intérieur ont tenu à se
rendre compte sur les lieux de
l'importance des dommages et de la mise
en action des secours fort bay comme à
melun où dans la banlieue parisienne
ils ont pu mesurer l'énormité de
l'épreuve qui a jusqu'ici motivé
l'évacuation de 5000 personnes et fait
des dizaines de milliers de sinistrés
[Musique]
on
à paris le zouave du pont de l'alma
jauge populaire en a jusqu'au coude
la cote de la grande crue de 1740 est
presque atteint la scène ne laisse plus
libre que la hauteur des parapets et la
gare des invalides abandonné n'est plus
qu'une berges sommet de débris au
secours officiels se sont jointes les
initiatives particulières
des pompes ont été appelés à vider les
sous-sols envahi par les infiltrations
mettait le boulanger a dû cependant pour
une journée faire son pain les pieds
dans l'eau
[Musique]
paris n'est plus à l'échelle des le
bateau-mouche bogue à la hauteur de la
rue dénicher bain de seine et maire est
à la hauteur des états et l'on imagine
devancé énorme masse d'eau qui dépasse
celle de 1910 ce qui aurait pu être la
catastrophe si depuis 40 ans certaines
précautions n'avait pas été pris sans
doute le mal a pu être limité mais c'est
pour ce début d'année un véritable
désastre
[Musique]